it's great to welcome back to the
program our old friend Bill share
contributing editor to Politico magazine
contributor to Real Clear Politics and
an ardent follower of the ins and outs
of election years in particular although
you know you're not just an election
year guy you're in year and year out but
things are getting more interesting and
what I have many many gears David yes of
course
so I mean listen just to start with what
is the trajectory for the next five and
a half months it's like is this election
going to happen in person is it going to
be vote-by-mail will it depend on state
by state people are talking about Trump
will try to delay it but he will fail I
just have no idea how to even think of
the next five and a half months well I
think he can't delay it he doesn't have
the power to delay it Congress would
never agree to delay it that won't
happen to the extent we're voting by
mail probably gonna be pretty patchwork
state-by-state some states will do a
better job and get ahead of the curve
some states will drag their feet and you
know what that means at the end of the
day is hard to project and as far as to
what extent this whole pandemic is going
to matter you know it's obviously a big
wild card but consider this we are in
May
we've already had in 2020 an impeachment
a ongoing pandemic and economic collapse
and a sexual assault allegation at the
Democratic nominee presumptive as well
not to mention of course the past's
allegations to the current president and
the numbers haven't moved very much you
know Biden has had a fairly stable lead
in the wheel Clear Politics average
generally between five and seven now
just on this past Friday in a tick down
to four point four that might be a
little statistical noise or it could be
a two-week Soutar read coverage as you
know brought down a little bit but you
go back to the fall such as to September
of 2019 Biden has never
in below four in the in his average
lead-in RCP and that is different than
Hillary Clinton people get people keep
saying Oh Hillary was ahead in the polls
so is by it in you can't trust that and
look things can change I'm not saying
Biden's a lock but their numbers are
different Hillary had dipped several
times going below for into a near tie or
an actual tie couple of times even
slightly behind between September 2015
and Election Day and in May of 2016
she had a big dip she some people were
saying by didn't bite it was worse than
Hillary in April yeah Hillary was
peaking in April April was when she was
ceiling just putting burning away and
there were some buyer's remorse on Trump
and Cruz is winning some primaries May
was when Trump locked it down Bernie's
still dogging Hillary and the FBI
investigation on the email servers was
really cranking up and she went from you
know we're on nine points to a tie by
the end of the month now she got she
bounced back up she was volatile she was
bouncing up and down not like every week
but some Biden has not done that much at
all
he had a narrowing with Purisima at the
turn of the year which got him down to
four moved back up into five and seven
now he's a little closer to four as of
today but it's not like Tara Reid is
becoming you know I'm the present in the
media so I wouldn't think that would
keep following the way Hillary did with
the email server investigation yeah I
want to talk about the Tara Reid thing
in a moment now one of the things in
2016 you hear this talking point the
polls were just wrong now I think it's
important when we look at that to say in
terms of the popular vote the polls were
essentially correct of course we have an
electoral college system and you can
find three states were about
seventy-five thousand votes push the
Electoral College over to trump that to
me seems I mean I know there's these
hypotheticals where you could win the
electoral college with 27% of the
popular vote we've never seen that and
it would have to be a crazy situation in
practice is three points of
popular vote difference roughly the most
that could still see the electoral
college go the other way and to put it a
different way if Biden wins the popular
vote by five
wouldn't it be incredibly like one in a
million that he would lose the electoral
college I mean some are better data
journalists like Dave Wasserman like
Nate Cohen or earlier earlier this year
late last year we're making the case
that Trump could win by five Trump could
lose popular vote by five points or more
yes and still win the electoral college
there are ways that can happen based on
how the demographics play out however
those projections were made before we
saw Biden's demographics Biden's demur
graphics are not Hillary's demographics
Biden does better much better with
seniors then Hillary did and Obama did
you look at Hillary and Obama's numbers
generationally it's a diagonal line
downward the older you get the less
democratic you are Biden's kind of a V I
think it's kind of soft around middle
age around Gen X and early boomers and
they comes back up with 65 and over and
so that may make a difference in states
with senior populations like Florida
like Arizona so and what we see today at
least when we see Biden you know around
4 to 7 in most polls Monmouth was 9 that
was kind of high-end CNBC was 3
there was one tie which was the
investment business daily
but generally 5 to 7 state polls in this
same period very good for Biden winning
in Florida winning in Arizona winning in
the industrial Midwest there's even one
where he was even up in Texas another
one was a tie yeah so if not getting not
a lock these are not like massive leads
that can't evaporate based on
circumstances in the future but you are
seeing Biden doing well in the swing
states while winning in the popular vote
by around five or so so Tara Reid my
sense of this situation is
there cannot possibly be what we would
call a conclusive investigation in into
the allegation said I'm going to talk
more about this on the program tomorrow
but to not do my segment tomorrow now
the gist of it is you've got a he-said
she-said situation the complaint that
Tara Reid says she filed but doesn't
mention sexual assault she doesn't have
a copy of and it's not clear what the
date is so I guess what I'm saying is
without criticizing or even evaluating
the truth of the claims there's not
enough to conclusively determine what
happened and thus something I don't know
what that something is I just think
there's a lot of people wanting
something conclusive which they're never
going to get what's your sense of it
well I won't put myself in the position
of being the adjudicator what's true or
what's not of course right that's the
thing I don't think we're gonna be able
to let me just try to talk about this in
the terms of I think the reaction
amongst Democrats yes and the reaction
in the media okay
Biden gave a response a week plus ago
that went over well with elected
Democrats you did not see any elected
Democrats criticize him you didn't see
anyone say take me out the Ring for VP
you didn't see the endorsement stop
coming you saw Democrats repeat his
messages he gave a statement which other
Democrats felt comfortable echoing
Democrats don't always do that that's it
that's a significant thing so number one
he kept his party in line with that
number - I think tar Reid has made some
PR mistakes again this is not a this is
not a bear on whether it's true or not
you like you can be you could be telling
the truth and make PR mistakes but I
think it was a mistake to not respond to
Biden quickly you know she canceled on
Fox she canceled on CNN so there and so
that created like a three four-day
period where some media coverage were
poking holes in the story and she wasn't
responding
and even though this might have gotten
wide pick up the vox recounting of what
tar wheat said they're actually true
there was an AP story and a spock story
that got into what she said in 2019 to
reporters that wasn't published at the
time and contrasting that with what was
said today and not just her but also one
of her anonymous corroborate errs and
the 2019 substance and tone was not
sexual you know what i wasn't scared by
him he wasn't gonna take me in a room
wasn't that kind of vibe the friend said
that he never kissed her
it just has a totally different tone and
context to what was being said today and
clearly that's had resonance in media
circles as well as democratic circles
where they're not as inclined to take
Watari to saying a straight face value
without adding in these mitigating
elements so what you find as megyn kelly
a decision to do a you know kind of a
big name but not on a TV platform on an
online platform you didn't see like if
she did a scene an exclusive that gets
looped on scene and all day long ya know
whatever whatever you think of the
veracity of it it's just it's gonna get
repeated and repeated and repeated you
debating you discuss it that didn't
happen with megyn kelly so all this
stuff about Biden side of the story and
the questions of tar weed story that had
time to settle and that did not get
reversed by the megyn kelly interview is
your sense that in six weeks this will
be a bigger part of the race or a
smaller part of the race it's gonna be I
think largely a non-factor unless
another shoe drops I mean yeah who could
have known that she had a neighbor that
she spoke to in 1986 you know come out
of nowhere you know somebody that
happens sure things could change but of
course someone accuses him of making a
verbal sexual harassment to a 14 year
old and it's debunked in 24 hours so
what comes out of the woodwork and
doesn't hold up to scrutiny
you know that's those are things that
are gonna matter whether this keeps
going now I could see regardless of what
happens going for
Donald Trump doing social media stuff
targeting younger people targeting women
trying to plant seeds of doubt you know
semi under the radar and see if you can
hurt by it on the margins he to this
stuff with Hillary you know very
successfully but that was a close race
that stuff works at a close race if it's
not a close race I don't think that
stuff matters so before the pandemic
really got going I had kind of a sense
that in large part November would be a
lot about the perception of the state of
the economy that's not any particularly
unique insight that that's it would just
it would just be that as it often is and
that's what made me think that polling
aside it was going to be very very
difficult to remove Donald Trump in
November with the completely failed
handling of the pandemic I started to
think maybe this is going to affect the
trajectory now a political scientist
Rachel bitter Kaufer a couple weeks ago
said she doesn't really think that
that's going to make a difference and I
want to try to parse through the idea of
maybe the handling of the pandemic
itself is baked in in the sense that
Trump's followers think he's doing fine
with it and a whole bunch of other
people don't believe that he's handled
it well but that that's not necessarily
going to change too many votes but isn't
that directly linked to the economy at
this point in the sense that isn't the
perception of the economy in
october/november going to relate
directly to what happens with the virus
sure and you know I like Rachel bit of
Hoffer a lot I've been a source of my
pieces I think she's great I generally
agree any more a political science view
then perhaps a campaign operative view a
political science u is generally look at
the fundamentals the stuff that
campaigns do tends to not have that much
of an impact at the end of the day at
best on the margins
I generally subscribe to that but this
is a bit unchartered territory you know
for example a political scientist might
say second quarter GDP is highly
determinative of the outcome if you're
on the rise people feel good about the
economy you know GDP numbers
tend to kind of filter through overtime
so how you how it feels on the ground
you know you don't feel it right away so
what happened in the second quarter
you'll feel by Election Day and that's
why that tends to have a correlation and
so if you are on a downward trend in the
second quarter even if things are
statistically picking up by November you
don't feel it yet like George Bush in
1992 and so that doesn't help you let me
explore that just briefly because the
timing so people understand second
quarters April May June it typically
takes about 35 days to get the numbers
so we would know around August 5th or
10th I think what the second quarter GDP
numbers were if they are indeed minus 20
is some are predicting you're talking
about a period starting in mid-august
which is actually much closer to the
election that than the second quarter
itself right it would it would seem
highly likely second quarter GDP will be
disastrous yeah and so you might punch
that into a model and say it's a done
deal
where I would pause is say this is a
little different than your usual
recession or depression yes maybe the
virus lifts by September and people
start shopping more robustly in October
and even though these statistics haven't
caught up to that you're feeling better
and your opinion of Trump is better now
I'm not saying I think that's a high
probability scenario I think it's what
we're likely this virus doesn't go away
at all and we're still stuck in our
homes for our extended period of time
yeah but that's the kinda thing that I
can't say with certainty what the bottom
line is do you feel you're we're getting
better we're getting worse and I'm not
sure we can use current numbers to know
that because this is such a highly
unusual situation yeah my message to my
audience has simply been I don't care
what state you vote in I don't care what
the polls say I don't care what the past
tells us about what happens when the
economy is bad improving whatever we
just really don't know and if you care
about removing Donald Trump just make
sure that you vote and get ten other
people to vote however you can do it
because it's just so unpredictable
well that's right now at any time an
election is gonna be close that kind of
GOTV can really matter right
you know if Wisconsin Michigan pens me
they came down to a handful of votes one
campaign isn't a little bit better than
the other yep that changed the whole
election now if we're in a situation
where the country is we decided this
Trump thing did not work that was a bad
idea multitude of ways and Biden's up by
you know seven points or whatever you
know getting five more your friends
doesn't matter not you're not saying
nothing you shouldn't do it let's say
you should take take a nap on Election
Day but I think Super Tuesday is
relevant here I mean then I talked with
us in a political article today Super
Tuesday was this fantastic real time
Poli Sci experiment what's more
important is it paid media who owns the
airwaves is it a ground game which is
often fueled by a lot of online
organizing these days or is it free
media Michael Bloomberg owned pay media
he just crushed paid media up and down
kept flooded the airwaves Bernie had the
ground game he had the online he had he
had the door-knocking he had the small
donor army and all that stuff
Biden was broke there were states he
didn't even visit but his free media
from Saturday to Tuesday was as golden
as has ever been and it wasn't just that
it was good it was communicating a
message that Democrats wanted to hear
who was electable who's gonna govern in
a sound insane way who's gonna unify the
party that all came together and that's
every two-hour period
anyone going away with some endorsements
in that bin that period as well well but
it's not like people did I mean most
endorsements don't matter right you know
Al Gore did not save howard dean
correctly the endorsements communicated
a message
yeah it was a very narrow scenario where
they actually made it
yes because it's unlike peabody judge
had that many votes to give never clover
chard that many votes to give or bidder
or orca that many votes to give but
there were people from different slices
of the party although generally on the
moderate side of things say hey if you
if you're not on for revolution
if you thought if you want a more
moderate pragmatic choice you could
unify the part of the country you have
one option and it's not Michael
Bloomberg it's not me Pete it's not me
Amy it's this guy and there were enough
Democrats who liked that message to
count consolidate around him without the
benefit of a strong campaign apparatus
so if the message in November is Trump
is doing a terrible job and Biden is a
sane competent alternative
you're not going need massive digital
operations or fantastic advertising to
win the election it's just going to be
baked in the fundamental dynamics of the
electorate bill scher contributing
editor to Politico magazine contributor
to Real Clear Politics will link to his
latest article that he referred to bill
always a pleasure having you on good
talk to you as well
take care